die pest ist die krankheit dem
mittelalter in europa millionen menschen
getötet hat breitet sich in madagaskar
in afrika aus alle paar tage verdoppeln
sich die fallzahlen was nichts gutes
ahnen lässt wie glücklich ist die
krankheit und wie bedrohlich ist sie für
uns jetzt sind links und sein verwischen
herzlich willkommen es gibt bereits mehr
als 100 tote und mehr als 1000
infizierte also zehn prozent der
erkrankten sterben eine extrem
gefährliche krankheit mit einer
unheimlichen geschichte der schwarze tod
im mittelalter grassierte die pest
unheimlich und tötete 25 millionen
menschen es war ein drittel aller
europäer eine der schlimmsten epidemien
überhaupt immer wieder gab es sie und
erst 1894 wurde der erreger vom
französischen arzt alexandre llosa
identifiziert und der übertragungsweg
geklärt hier in europa taucht die pest
seitdem kaum noch auf aber immerhin in
21 anderen ländern vereinzelt sogar in
den usa in madagaskar ist die pest seit
2008 wieder vermehrt aufgetreten und hat
jetzt zu der schlimmsten epidemie
geführt dort wie so oft fängt alles mit
einem einzelnen fall an der durch ganz
bestimmte umstände zu einer massenweisen
verbreitung führt bei ebola war es eine
riesige beerdigung bei der alle gäste
den leichnam an fasten und sich dann
wieder in alle himmelsrichtungen
zerstreut und die solche so verbreiteten
beim aktuellen test ausbruch in
madagaskar war es ein busreisende der
alle mitreisenden in einem bus
ansteckten so zur verbreitung bei druck
wie bei ebola ist es im nachhinein
unmöglich die infizierten auszumachen
und zu isolieren die seuche verbreitet
sich wie in europa im mittelalter kamen
auch in madagaskar die solche mit
schiffen aus asien das bakterium
yersinia pestis fragen ratten in sich
sie werden von flöhen gebissen die das
bakterium dann über flohbisse auf andere
wirte eben auch den menschen übertragen
dabei kann die pest auf drei arten
ausbrechen bei der pest
blutvergiftung da gehen die bakterien
die bleiben im blut und töten innerhalb
von ein paar tagen bei der beulenpest
sie liehen sie sich in den lymphknoten
an die tennisballgroßen schwellen und
wenn diese platzen dann verbreiten sich
die bakterien und stecken andere
menschen an am ansteckendsten ist die
lungenpest hier sind die bakterien in
der lunge und werden durch die atemluft
zb beim pusten vor allen dingen
verbreitet genau der fall der die
epidemie über den mitreisenden im bus
verbreitet hat jetzt ist dieser ausbruch
zum größten ausbruch der pest in afrika
geworden und ein ende ist nicht
abzusehen
die menschen schlafen hier und das ist
ein schwieriger und stand zum teil in
hütten auf dem boden krankenhäuser und
ärzte die sind weit entfernt ideale
voraussetzung für die ausbreitung der
epidemie hat sich hier jemand infiziert
hat er einige tage zeit die erreger zu
verbreiten die langen reaktionszeiten am
jetzt dazu geführt dass der erreger die
hauptstadt antananarivo
und überhaupt städte erreicht hat in
denen er sich viel viel schneller
ausbreiten und deutlich mehr menschen
infizieren kann
die regierung hat jetzt versammlungen
und kundgebungen verboten doch das
scheint nicht viel zu nützen millionen
menschen drängen sich in den städten in
den öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln und
tragen die solche soweit im moment sieht
es nicht so aus dass die solche
eingegrenzt werden könnte dabei gäbe es
ganz gute behandlungsmethoden gegen die
pest zwar sind die bakterien inzwischen
gegen einige antibiotika resistent wie
inzwischen in madagaskar festgestellt
wurde aber es gibt noch genügend
antibiotika die wenn er kein video zum
thema noch zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollt dann wird mir hier ein
aber aufs auge vergessen sich den
auf die glocke damit auch wirklich
benachrichtigt werden wenn ein neues
video kommt und hier geht es weiter mit
droht eine pandemie
dann geht es um das extrem gefährliche
virus sich moment verbreitet ansonsten
bis dann